hi there steve kaufman here
um i'm looking forward to going to
prague it's less than a month away
i arrive in the evening of the 1st of
october and i depart around noon on the
6th
i would like to have a meet up
in the evening of the 2nd of october
somewhere in prague
a number of uh
people that i'm in touch with in prague
are going to come to dinner we've got
say three or four we'd like to have a
bigger group any of you that are in the
area that would like to come to dinner
please join us and we haven't picked a
place because i must say i don't know
where to go in prague but i'd like to go
somewhere where we can have a
a simple
czech meal and some czech beer
and without it being too expensive and
we can just uh uh chat
uh i must say that my goal
in the uh
five days in prague is to activate my
passive knowledge of check so i want to
speak
check exclusively for five days
my hope is that this extensive or
intensive exposure to check i'll be
listening on the radio reading the
newspapers talking to people hearing
people
uh that this is going to activate the
quite significant passive knowledge of
check that i have accumulated over the
past year or so
so i welcome you please let me know if
you're going to be there if you would
like to come on the second and if you
have any ideas suggestions
of where we could meet up
and i'm going to continue this in check
uh
it will be the first time that i've had
a sort of a
typical unrehearsed video in check i
have
put up some examples of me speaking to
my tutors but that's in a way easier to
do because they initiate the
conversation
um
so
says nazim i should say one more thing
before i get in there one of the
difficulties is when you speak in a
language that you haven't spoken much
you're not sure about how these words
are used you're not sure if if taking
some of the words that you have learned
and then trying to apply them in a
conversation is appropriate or not uh to
me there's a big issue in language
learning of
credibility so you have all these words
you're not sure how to use them
uh so when i proceed now to speak in
check i'm sure i will use them
inappropriately but it doesn't matter
at some point you have to get out there
and try these things
and of course it's much better if it's
not a monologue because then you're
getting an instant feedback not
necessarily in the form of corrections
although that might also be the case but
very often
the person you're speaking with will
pick up on what you've said and phrase
it in some way that represents more
standard usage so this is an opportunity
for me to speak without that kind of
feedback so it probably will sound very
strange to check ears
foreign